[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat les missions qui
vous fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée avec une audition importante
aujourd'hui celle de maxime saada le pdg
du groupe canal+ et de la plateforme
dailymotion deux entités propriété de
l'industriel vincent bolloré je vous
laisse écouter cette audition
monsieur saada vous êtes rentré en 2004
dans le groupe canal+ comme directeur de
la stratégie en 2016 vous êtes nommé
directeur général et enfin président du
directoire en avril
2018 vous avez donc participé aux
premières loges aux évolutions du groupe
notamment le lancement de la chaîne
d'information i télé en 2005 l'arrivée
de vincent bolloré à la tête de vivendi
en 2014 et les nombreux soubresauts des
droits sportifs entre autres je me
rappelle également de vos propos en juin
2018 devant la commission de la culture
sur le sort de canalplay nous avions
entendu de votre part un langage direct
et franc vous aviez alors estimé que la
décision de l'autorité de la concurrence
prises lors de la fusion avec tps avait
littéralement achevé canalplay et ouvert
la voie au succès colossal des
plateformes de l'aide flix et d'amazon
avec commission d' enquête est donc très
heureuse de vous entendre au titre de
votre fonction de vos fonctions d'autant
plus que la semaine dernière où il ya
quinze jours je ne sais plus monsieur
bolloré nous a dit que il est décidé de
rien dans le groupe et que c'était
vous qui décidez donc on a évidemment
des questions à vous poser
sur deux sujets qui sont au coeur des
préoccupations de notre commission
d'une part la nature et la réalité de
vos relations avec votre actionnaire
vivendi en particulier dans le domaine
de l'information et je pense en
particulier à ces news dont nous avons
entendu au début des travaux de notre
commission le directeur de l'information
et puis d'autre part vivendi et canal
sont au coeur des opérations de
concentration ces dernières années votre
groupe est désormais un acteur majeur de
l'information de la distribution de la
production des droits sportifs
que pouvez-vous nous dire sur cette
course au gigantisme et aux conséquences
que ça sur la structuration du paysage
audiovisuel
je vous propose l'organisation suivante
commune à toutes nos auditions je vais
vous laisser la parole pour dix minutes
vendant bien sûr de respecter les dix
minutes tout simplement pour que nous
puissions après vous poser des questions
et vous puissiez à travers vos réponses
développer tel ou tel point que vous
n'aurez pas pu aborder dans vos propos
liminaire je vous précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site de public sénat et elle fera
également l'objet d'un compte rendu qui
sera publié enfin je rappelle pour la
forme d'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission denquête seraient passibles
des peines prévues aux articles 434 13
14 15 du code pénal je vous précise
également qu'il vous appartient le cas
échéant d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts au conflit d'intérêts en
relation avec l'objet de la commission
denquête je vais vous invitez maintenant
monsieur saada a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure je le jure je vous remercie et donc
je vous donne la parole pour dix minutes
que monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur mais l'année sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs si vous le
permettez je vais commencer brièvement
par rappeler mon parcours j'ai débuté ma
carrière dans la fonction publique en
1994 au sein de l'antenne nord
américaine de la datar où j'étais en
charge de favoriser les investissements
industriels américains en france j'ai
rejoint cinq ans plus tard le cabinet de
conseil mckinsey avant d'intégrer un
groupe canal+ en 2004 où j'ai occupé
successivement neuf postes de directeur
de la stratégie à directeur des
programmes en passant notamment par la
direction commerciale
ou la direction des sports j'ai été
nommé directeur général du groupe en
2015 puis président du directoire en
2018 j'ai donc la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des activités du groupe
canal+ celle de télévision payante et
gratuite en france et à l'international
ainsi qu'à celle de studiocanal notre
fusion européen de production et de
distribution de films et de séries c'est
à ce titre que je m'exprime devant vous
aujourd'hui j'ai vu au cours de mes 18
dernières années chez canal+
le marché se transformer en profondeur
notamment sous l'effet du développement
d'internet et de l'émergence
d'opérateurs systémique internationaux
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer devant
vous directement en 2016
qu'est ce qui a changé pour canal+
depuis
toutes les dynamiques se sont accélérées
le marché de la vidéo par abonnement est
aujourd'hui dominé par des plateformes
américaines mondialisé qui dispose de
plusieurs centaines de millions
d'abonnés à travers le monde cette
taille leur permet d'investir
massivement dans les contenus disney
investir à 33 milliards de dollars cette
année netflix 19 la croissance de ces
chiffres est quasi exponentielle
ces investissements ne sont d'ailleurs
pas exclusivement consacrée à la
production de contenus ils sont parfois
utilisés à verrouiller l'accès des
talents ou à des propriétés
intellectuelles
les contenus américains capte
l'essentiel de ses investissements
puisqu'ils sont considérés comme les
plus exportables l'hégémonie culturelle
américaine s'est donc largement
renforcée à travers le monde et
notamment en france
vous trouverez par exemple seulement un
contenu français dans le top 10 des
contenus les plus regardées en france
sur netflix en france un seul sur dix en
sur le cinéma en 2010 neuf dernières
années non impactés par la crise
sanitaire sur les quinze films ayant
réalisé le plus d'entrées en salles en
france 13 étaient américains
dans le même temps les studios
américains ont initié à leur tour une
stratégie consistant à lancer
directement leurs plateformes c'est le
cas de disney warner paramount et
universal ils ont dorénavant tous un
lien direct avec le consomme un
consommateur final et ils sont tous à la
recherche d'une taille critique une
vague de consolidation s'est donc
enclenché
comme en témoignent les récentes
acquisitions de warner par discovery de
mgm par amazon ou encore de fox par
disney
six acteurs américains se partagent
aujourd'hui l'essentiel du marché de la
vidéo payante dans le monde et nous
concurrencent sur tous nos marchés
canal+ fait figure de challenger y
compris sur son marché d'origine la
france
notre groupe est le seul et unique
fleurot européen indépendant depuis le
rachat de skype par l'américain comcast
en 2018
ce contexte aurait pu nous faire peur
il nous a motivés nous avons vu face à
cette hégémonie culturelle américaine
une opportunité de marché en proposant
une offre différenciante fondée sur les
cultures française et européenne
c'est au service de cette ambition que
le groupe canal+ est complètement
réinventé depuis nos derniers échanges
en 2016
en france où les chaînes canal+ ont
perdu et je vais être précis sur ce
sujet
452 millions d'euros sur la période 2014
nous avons entamé un plan d'économies le
plus de 2 milliards qui nous a permis
d'investir massivement dans la création
de diviser par deux le prix d'accès à
canal+ pour retrouver la compétitivité
de lancer de nouvelles offres digitales
à moins de 10 euros pour séduire les
plus jeunes et de transformer le modèle
de canal+ en distributeurs
d'applications puisque nous avons agrégé
successivement netflix puis disney + et
plus récemment star plaît
surtout le groupe canal+ s'est
internationalisé
la vidéo par abonnement est un marché de
coûts fixes il y a donc un enjeu de
taille critique pour l'ensemble des
acteurs afin de mieux amortir les coûts
plus d'un opérateur à d'abonnés - le
prix de revient par abonné d'une série
d'un film est important prenez par
exemple le film netflix dit irishman de
scorsese au budget de 150 millions de
dollars pour netflix avec 222 millions
d'abonnés cela revient à 60 centimes par
abonné pour canal+ cela reviendrait à
6,020 par abonné
c'est pourquoi les plateformes
américaines se sont mondialisés
ce défi de la taille le groupe canal+
parti relever depuis 2016 nous avons
doublé le nombre de nos abonnés en cinq
ans en passant de 11 millions en 2015 à
près de 22 millions d'abonnés en 2020
dans plus de 40 pays à travers le monde
et sur ses 22 millions d'abonnés plus de
treize sont désormais hors de france
nous avons doublé le nombre de nos
abonnés en europe tripler le nombre de
ses abonnés en afrique est largement
franchi la barre du million d'abonnés en
asie
nous nous sommes dans le même temps
digitalisées avec notre application my
canal nous investissons chaque année
plus de 100 millions d'euros dans le
développement de ses actifs
technologiques clés et nous avons
déployé cet actif dans une grande partie
nos territoires à travers le monde
enfin nous avons renforcé nos
investissements dans les contenus le
coeur du réacteur comme en témoigne la
montée en puissance de studiocanal qui
produit et distribue une trentaine de
films par an dans le monde les films
anglais et allemands mais aussi les plus
grands succès du cinéma français comme
le démontrent les succès public et
critique de bac nord boîtes noires et de
son vivant et leurs treize nominations
aux césars reçu avant-hier
studio canal s'est également renforcée
dans les séries avec une trentaine de
fictions produites et distribuées chaque
année grâce à nos neuf sociétés de
productions européennes en france mais
aussi en angleterre en espagne en
pologne en allemagne au danemark
nous développons également de plus en
plus de fictions d'ambitions
internationales pour canal+ le plus
souvent ancrés en france comme
versailles baron noir valider ou encore
hippocrate elles sont en large majorité
produit par des sociétés de production
indépendantes
à titre d'exemple une seule création
originale a été produite par studio
canal en france en 2021 sur les neuf que
nous avons diffusé
nos investissements dans sport ont
également fortement augmenté ces
dernières années le renouvellement du
top 14 jusqu'en 2027 en est l'une des
dernières illustrations
canal+ est devenu en 2021
le premier diffuseur mondial de la ligue
des champions
et enfin notre nouvel accord avec les
organisations du cinéma en france
prévoit un investissement minimum de
canal+ dans le cinéma français et
européen de plus de 600 millions d'euros
sur les trois prochaines années
au global nous aurons investi 3,4
milliards d'euros dans la création et
les contenus en 2021
j'aimerais souligner que ce projet
économique est rentable et rationnelle
notre résultat opérationnel
est passé de 281 millions d'euros en
2016 à 477 millions d'euros en 2020 ces
résultats sont quasi exclusivement porté
par nos activités à l'international
au moins aussi important la satisfaction
de nos abonnés n'a jamais été aussi
élevée sur les cinq dernières années et
l'image de la marque canal + s'est
considérablement renforcée nous sommes
la seule marque française dans
classement brandz heinz 2021 des marques
médias mondiales les plus valorisées
nous avons également été élue pour la
troisième année consécutive entreprises
préférées des étudiants et jeunes
diplômés dans la catégorie média en
france
cette excellence opérationnelle nous a
permis d'obtenir la confiance et le
soutien total de notre actionnaire
vivendi nous a ainsi accompagner dans
notre développement en nous soutenant
sur plusieurs investissements majeurs
l'acquisition pour plus de 1 milliard
d'euros du groupe emme seven opérateurs
de télévision payante dans sept pays
d'europe de l'est
l'acquisition récente de spa
international éditeur de chaînes cinéma
dans 30 pays et nous sommes devenus le
premier actionnaire de multichoice le
leader de la télévision payante en
afrique anglophone et lusophone
mais malgré tout cela notre position
reste marginal au niveau mondial sur le
marché de la vidéo par abonnement no 22
millions d'abonnés doit se comparer aux
222 netflix aux plus de 200 millions d'
amazon et aux 118 millions de disney
plus
en 2020 nous avons certes réussi
l'exploit d'enregistrer une croissance
nette de parcs de 260 milles abonnés en
france mais dans le même temps elle fixe
ont gagné 2 millions
en regardant ces équilibres
concurrentiel je me demande simplement
si la concentration en france et le
coeur du sujet
j'ai pu constater que le dispositif
anti-concentration domestique utilisé à
plein était jusqu'à présent efficaces
pour réguler les consolidations dans les
médias
nous avons nous-mêmes été régulier sur
l'ensemble de nos métiers pour
l'acquisition de tps pendant plus de
treize ans et certains engagements
perdure même jusqu'en 2024 pour les
outre mer soit 17 ans après la fusion
par ailleurs force est de constater
comme l'a fait monsieur olivier mestre
président de l'arq l'homme que le marché
français est moins concentré que par le
passé
en télévision nous sommes ainsi passés
de 3 chaînes publiques dans les années
80 trente chaînes nationales aujourd'hui
sur la tnt et 230 sur les autres modes
de diffusion
toutes les voix s'expriment aujourd'hui
en france est ce plus que jamais
une fois ce constat effectué et je
terminerai par là reste une question
importante peut-on trouver les modèles
créer des ensembles qui coexiste avec
ces géants mondiaux je suis convaincu
que nous en avons la capacité
les acteurs français sont bien leaders
mondiaux du luxe de l'aéronautique ou
des cosmétiques pourquoi n'en serait-il
pas de même pour la culture
vivendi et canal + sont prêts à relever
ce défi canal+ est présent dans plus de
50 pays
j'ai annoncé récemment un objectif de 30
millions d'abonnés minimum d'ici à 2025
nous avons fait la démonstration que des
contenus européens pouvaient connaître
un énorme succès à l'international avec
le bureau des légendes ou paddington
pendant siete que deux
mais il ne faut pas nous entraver
davantage
il existe déjà beaucoup d'asymétrie avec
les acteurs globaux des écarts de
puissance financière bien sûr mais
surtout des asymétries normative liés
aux obligations d'investissement dans la
création encore aux obligations de
diffusion
il bénéficie de par leur taille et leur
plasticité d'une capacité à se
développer mondialement de façon
opportuniste en lissant les contraintes
qu'ils peuvent éventuellement trouver
dans tel ou tel pays
il existe aujourd'hui beaucoup de freins
à l'internationalisation des acteurs
français à commencer par la non
détention des droits des oeuvres
audiovisuelles qui financent quasi tra
intégralement le sénat connaît ce sujet
nous n'avons pas les mêmes moyens et
nous ne jouons pas avec les mêmes règles
le risque est contré temps une
hypothétique concentration nationale
nous rendions plus complexe encore le
développement de nos fleurons nationaux
à l'étranger je le redis la culture
française est un atout majeur elle
fascine le monde entier il s'agit d'une
chance que nous avons décidé de saisir
efforts de nos succès récents une
aventure qui nous anime et nous porte
chez canal+
je me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci mais je
suis ça va les premières questions vont
arriver avec que celle de david
assouline
merci monsieur salah de nous avoir
exposé votre parcours et les résultats
de votre groupe
en particulier dans le domaine
de la vidéo et
du cinéma
et tout le monde c'est en france
que le notamment le cinéma
repose
sur une jambe
sur deux jambes mais sur ton dont l'une
et canal+ et
nous sommes toujours attentifs dans la
au sénat et dans la commission des
affaires culturelles ont fait que cet
investissement qui était à la base même
de votre création et des droits que vous
avez acquis grâce à cet engagement
puisse perdurer
mais vous savez très bien et le
président l'a dit en entrée que ce sujet
de la concentration pour nous va dans
deux directions
une direction vous avez traité avec un
point de vue
la concentration au niveau économique
avec cet argument de faire face aux
grandes plate-formes dans un marché
mondialisé
vous trouvez d'ailleurs par tout ce que
vous avez développé
et en nous assurant que votre groupe vit
bien et se développe que ya moyen sont
ressembler à ces plateformes de vivre et
de faire même des bénéfices mais vous
avez un point de vue et c'est un point
de vue économique que nous allons
traiter avec avantages inconvénients
nécessité de grands investissements dans
un domaine où ça coûte cher la
production et la distribution dans cet
environnement et la nécessité de
maintenir une diversité et un pluralisme
de l'autre tant sur le plan culturel
puisque vous parlez de culture française
mais dans cette culture française ce qui
est peut-être le plus marquant dans ce
que nous revendiquons par rapport à
d'autres pays
c'est justement son sa diversité et est
donc c'est important de pouvoir la
maintenir mais aussi dans le domaine de
l'information ça vous n'avez absolument
rien dit des problématiques que des
groupes géants
verticaux
possédant de façon aussi horizontale
nombreux médias
pas seulement
télévisée mais aussi radio est écrit et
dans le domaine de l'édition et dans le
domaine de la publicité ce qui fait
quand même une chaîne peuvent en quoi ça
peut atteindre à cette diversité
pluralisme et liberté des journalistes
et de l'information alors j'ai
une première question parce que
voilà on a la chance ici de pouvoir
auditionner tout le monde
parce que c'est un devoir de venir et
donc on a pu auditionner
votre propriétaire ou à dire monsieur
bolloré comme on le fait pour tous les
autres gros pc c'est l'originalité de
ses auditions aussi c'est que des
personnalités qui parle peu viennent
répondre et dire ce qu'elles ont à dire
et ce qui était très marquants et
relever c'est que il a dit moi je
n'interviens dans rien
rien et a des gens compétents pour cela
et notamment vous alors
j'espère que là on va avoir les réponses
la charte la convention qui vous lie
au csa pour senio qui est une des
chaînes de votre groupe qu'on n'allait
même pas évoquée alors vous savez que
c'est comme un mot au coeur de
l'attention de tout le monde puisqu'il
s'agit de l'information dit la chose
suivante
l'éditeur assure le pluralisme de
l'expression des courants de pensée et
d'opinion notamment dans le cas des
recommandations formulées par le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel
et notamment ce qui concerne le
pluralisme politique mais le plus rêver
mieux comme
plus générale
il dit ensuite
l'éditeur veille dans son programme à ne
pas inciter à des pratiques ou
comportements dangereux délinquants ou
inciviques à respecter les différentes
sensibilités politiques culturelles et
religieuses du pays à ne pas encourager
des comportements discriminatoires en
raison de la race ou de l'origine du
sexe de l'orientation sexuelle de la
religion de la nationalité à promouvoir
les valeurs d'intégration et de
solidarité qui sont celles de la
république et lutter contre les
discriminations
donc c'est très précis très clair et
vous savez que et par des mises en
demeure et par des mises en garde
nombreuses puisque vous avez le record
avec cette chaîne notamment mais en
général
beaucoup voit notamment avec la façon
dont a été mis sur orbite monsieur
zemmour qui bleus n'en est candidat à la
présidentielle et non pas président
comme monsieur bolloré l'a dit
que beaucoup de témoignages beaucoup de
faits rapportés par la presse montrent
qu' il y a une volonté de
faire une chaîne d'opinion or ce que je
viens de vous lire
interdire tous les cas écarte toute
possibilité que votre chaîne
d'information puisse être une chaîne
d'opinion que me répondez vous à cette
remarque
sur le rapporteur je vais
vomir c'est pour vous monsieur le cinéma
en effet parce que je me souviens que
lors de l'audition 2016 vous aviez
exprimé des inquiétudes sur le sujet et
sur un retrait possible de canal plus
et on déplie de d'efforts de certains et
de ce que nous considérons comme un
quasi favoritisme des plateformes
américaines dans les démarches qui ont
été entreprises parfois par le
gouvernement on a démontré notre
attachement au cinéma français on s'est
engagé sur un investissement supérieur à
tout ce qu'on a fait dans le passé et on
est le jeu le rappelle le seul acteur
abordé aujourd'hui des engagements de
diversité puisqu'on parle de diversité
culturelle
avec les 200 millions que nous
investissons que nous investirons
parents sont plus de 170 sur canal+ plus
de
plus de la moitié des films de la
diversité à moins de 4 millions d'euros
plus d'un tiers des films des premiers
ou deuxièmes films et pour beaucoup des
films qui ne sont soutenus par aucune
chaîne hertzienne qui n'existeraient pas
sans canal +
alors sur ses news je les ai pas
mentionné j'ai pas mentionner toutes les
chaînes ce serait très long
payante 0 6%
0 4% du chiffre d'affaires du groupe
canal+ je vois là je suis d'abord un
gestionnaire et je consacre l'essentiel
de mon temps aux sujets qui ont le plus
d'impact économique sur sur le groupe
canal plus est il est vrai que je me
suis pas
épanché sur sur la chaîne d'information
qui représente au moins 0 5% de notre
chiffre d'affaires
sur les mises en demeure alors oui on
peut pas reprocher au csa de ne pas
s'occuper de ses news je crois
avec des innovations assez régulière
comme des mises en demeure préventive
sur le temps de parole avant même que
les périodes
soit écoulée c'était une première
d'ailleurs on a fait la démonstration au
31 décembre on avait parfaitement
respecté les temps de parole je le
rappelle pour ceux qu'on parle beaucoup
de beaucoup de faire comme vous dites
beaucoup de choses qui sont rapportés
dans la presse mais moi je regarde la
réalité des choses et la réalité des
choses c'est qu'au 31 décembre nous
avons respecté le temps de parole en
dépit de cette ces mises en demeure
inédite 1 inédite préventive sur avant
que la période soit écoulé c'était quand
même assez assez intéressant et je
profite pour vous donner le relais du
csa sur la période du 1er janvier au 16
janvier 2022 qui vient de s'écouler
6h49 de temps de parole pour emmanuel
macron et ses soutiens sur ses news
c'est plus que bfm 5h20 c'est trois fois
plus que france info 12h29 seule valérie
pécresse est devant sur ces news sur
cette période jean luc mélenchon est
troisième avec 6h23 et eric zemmour est
quatrième avec 5h09
5h09 de temps de parole pour examiner
ses soutiens sur ses news c - bfmtv qui
fait 6h19 et c'est à peu près la même
chose que lci sur la période
ça c'est sur le temps de parole en temps
d'antenne lci est loin devant ces news
8h42 et bfm 7h46 avec une 10h46
d'antenne sur eric zemmour ça c'est sur
la période qui vient de s'écouler
repréciser la période 1er au 16 janvier
2022 oui
la dernière c'est le chiffre du csa oui
juste une remarque comme ça où
on avance
bien entendu vous parlez des quinze
derniers jours quoi en fait non j'ai
aussi parlé de la période du 31 décembre
qui s'est écoulé à la fin de l'année
dernière sur lesquels on avait une mise
en demeure et l'entier vous avez noté
nous avons respecté le temps de parole
nous avons systématiquement un spectacle
paroles on nous a jugés avant que la
période soit écoulée c'est encore une
fois c'est une première la même façon
que le csa nous a indiqué qu'il y avait
un sujet sur le temps de parole qui
était qui s'est passé pendant la nuit
ils étaient une pratique absolument
courante de toutes les chaînes
d'information celle n'y avait pas de
règles sur ce sujet là qu'à partir du
moment où le csa a indiqué qu'il y avait
un sujet là dessus nous nous sommes
conformés c'est compliqué se conformer à
des règles avant même que les périodes
soit soit écoulé mais le csa il me
semble par rapport à ce que vous dites
sur est ce que ces news respecte la
convention clairement je respecte je dis
que oui et il me semble qu'on peut pas
taxer le csa de laxisme en ce qui
concerne ses news vous l'avez dit
vous-même nous faisons manifestement
nous attirons beaucoup l'attention du
csa qui passent beaucoup de temps devant
les antennes de ces news il croyait bien
s'ils avaient quelque chose à nous à
nous reprocher alors effet ce jeu je
continue là dessus après j'ai une
question plus globale de
sur les types de concentration verticale
notamment le rôle d'ava c'est de la
publicité qui qui est un sujet qui a
émergé dans cette commission et qui a
son intérêt avec aussi le lien avec
l'édition mais concrètement
vous ne pouvez pas réduire la convention
que je viens de lire au respect du temps
d'antenne politique est très réglementée
notamment à partir du 1er janvier quand
vous citez ces chiffres précis où il y à
des obligations très claires
parce qu'on rentre dans une période de
campagne présidentielle
où on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
donc j'ai étendu à mon propos
qu'en le lisant la convention
et je vous ai posé une question très
clair sur chaîne d'opinion ou pas chaîne
d'opinions tout ce qui est fait depuis
maintenant un bon bout de temps sur ses
news en termes de choix de des mateurs
terme de thématique ou terme
d'éditoriaux et
un affichage revendiqué
de ce qui anime les émissions
de caractère des invités qui n'avaient
pas leur place sur les plateaux
télévision parce que le négationnisme
et des théories racistes n'avaient pas
leur place sur les plateaux de
télévision de chaînes d'information qui
recevait un agrément du csa
vous pouvez pas me réduire cela a
maintenant le temps d'antenne des
politiques est respecté à la veille de
la présidentielle donc je vous demande
concrètement si ça se fait tout seul
si c'est monsieur bolloré qui vous
demandent de favoriser cela aussi c'est
vous puisque lui dit qu'il n'y est pour
rien
qu'ils intervenaient sur le contenu
éditorial pour favoriser le fait que
c'est une chaîne d'opinion et de plus en
plus d'opinions 10 des extrêmes et
dangereuse pour la république
alors parlons je reviens sur vos propos
nous n'avons jamais n'ai jamais manqué
de respect sur le temps de parole nous
avons toujours respecté le temps de
parole à toute période sur toutes les
périodes vous parlez que de la quinte
dernière quinzaine je je je le répète
sur toutes les périodes écoulée nous
n'avons jamais eu un problème de respect
du temps de parole voilà au moment où
les périodes était écoulé
le sujet quand même sur sur ces news
répondre à mes questions là je vous les
chaînes d'opinion saverne d'opinion et
le traitement je vais le faire là bas un
observateur qui considère qu'aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas une chaîne d'opinion est
dit est réalisé dans un certain sens
dans
sa réponse justement les observateurs
vous avez indiqué vous même lors de la
session l'audition de thomas modèle que
vous regardiez pas ses news donc je me
fie aux observateurs qui regardent la
chaîne pour moi c'est pas une chaîne
d'opinion on part d'une situation de 33
millions d'euros de déficit en 2016
c'est ça la situation de ces news
pourquoi ces news est dans cette
situation parce qu'on a le record du
monde du 200m d'information gratuite
avec un passage de lci en clair dont on
s'écrit pas complètement la nécessité
est derrière la chaine france info qui a
été créée quatre chaînes gratuites plus
toutes les chaînes où l'information est
reprise qui n'ont fait qu'aggraver le
déficit de cette chaîne 33 millions
d'euros moi je je je vais revenir sur
sur mon parcours peut-être mais je suis
pas un idéologue je suis un gestionnaire
je pense que c'est pour ça que j'ai été
recruté par vincent bolloré
33 millions déficit c'est pas possible
c'est pas durable c'est pas pérenne on
parle de diversité on parle de
pluralisme si toutes les chaînes
d'information disparaît sous toutes les
chaînes d'informations privées on a un
problème
32 millions de pertes à l'époque pour
lci donc j'irai la situation est de même
nature
notre réflexion et comment est-ce qu'on
résorber ce déficit est le sujet pour
nous c'est de se différencier sur un
marché qui est pléthorique
le sujet l'analyse qu'on fait c'est con
à bfm qui est sur un positionnement de
breaking news qu'on n'a pas la capacité
de suivre parce qu'il est très coûteux
et vous savez bien fait mais la seule un
chat un chat d'informations privées
rentable
et ils font un travail remarquable gg
absolument pas de critiques à apporter à
cette chaîne et nous notre souhait c'est
de nous différencier et donc on part
dans une logique de durée d'ecoute en
disant on va pas pouvoir faire du
breaking news et d'informations brutes
aussi aussi aussi aussi clairement que
le fai bfm et donc on va aller dans une
durée d'ecoute dans une logique de durée
d'ecoute pour que les téléspectateurs
restent davantage et pour générer du
revenu publicitaire et donc à partir de
là on part sur une notion de débat qui
est la réalité du positionnement
éditorial aujourd'hui vous vous dites
chaînes d'opinion moi je dis non donc je
réponds clairement à votre à votre
question c'est une chaîne de débats où
toutes les opinions avons vocation à
s'exprimer c'est ça la réalité et c'est
bien pour ça que le succès de ces news
est arrivé parce que il ya des opinions
qui se sont retrouvés sur cette chaîne
parce qu'elles étaient exprimées et
potentiellement ne l'était pas ailleurs
quand vous avez un positionnement sur la
durée avec des opinions qui sont toutes
les opinions qui sont représentés à
l'antenne et ben vous avez des
téléspectateurs qui ne les entendez pas
et qui tout d'un coup se retrouve
votre stratégie de ce point de vue là
est très clair et je comprends que vous
l'avez dit vous êtes gestionnaire donc
vous vous essayez aussi de développer
les parts d'audience sur l'ensemble des
des médias et donc ses news on comprend
les problématiques de gestion mais
comprenez qu'il ya pas non plus que des
problématiques de gestion quand on
dirait jamais dire
le le comité d'éthique structure interne
à canal+ et mid et des réserves des
remarques sur l'émission face à l'info
en préconisant un changement de format
et en demandant qui est un contradicteur
par rapport à l'intervenant principal
qui est en l'occurrence eric zemmour
vous n'avez pas suivi les
recommandations du comité d'éthique
d'abord qui a pris la décision de ne pas
suivre le comité d'éthique et pourquoi
vous ne l'avez pas suivi
alors d'abord le comité d'éthique et si
vous aussi vous interroger chacun de ses
membres et vous le dira
contre cannes où l'asie à nous il a dit
au csa les relations avec le comité
d'éthique sont fréquentes et ils nous
ont indiqué que même quand en discutant
en échangeant avec d'autres membres
d'autres comités éthiques il avait le
sentiment d'être le comité d'éthique le
plus sollicité et le plus actif à paris
ils nous ont fait un certain nombre de
recommandations
la première c'était d'introduire du
différé nous avons suivi cette
recommandation
donc il ya bien une recommandation qui a
été suivie
jeu nettement je n'ai pas souvenir d'une
recommandation qui n'a pas été suivi sur
la contradiction donc nous considérons
que précisément il y a eu
systématiquement contradiction en face
d'eric zemmour avec de nombreux
ministres des intellectuels de tous
rangs d'aidé
des des politiques de tous horizons
des chefs d'entreprise
donc je ne me souviens pas qu'on n'ait
pas suivi de recommandations nature tout
cas pour nous la contradiction existe et
pour répondre à votre question c'est moi
qui pensais de décisions l'occurrence
c'est moi qui l'ait prise donc si j'ai
bien compris vous n'avez pas répondu
précisément mais vous avez quand même
dit quelque chose qui est assez
intéressant fait donc vous n'êtes pas
une chaîne d'opinion mais vous vous
dites on n'est pas une chaîne
d'information mais une chaîne de débats
vous n'avez pas reçu d'agrément du csa
pour être une chaîne de débats
premièrement donc vous êtes une chaîne
d'information et ensuite la question du
pluralisme vous dit en gros vous le lier
à votre statut de gestionnaire vous
dites nous il faut fauqué du public il
faut que ce soit rentable et donc en
gros on a choisi de faire du trash en
termes dîner parce que ça ça permet de
faire de l'audimat et donc vous n'avez
pas été organisées du débat de société
qui permet d'éclairer les citoyens mais
vous avez été chercher ceux
effectivement tu n'étais pas sur les
plateaux mais pour cause parce qu'on
république on ne met pas sur les
plateaux impunément des gens qui prônent
le négationnisme de théories racistes
qui ont provoqué beaucoup de morts aux
etats unis comme celle du grand
remplacement
et je peux vous citer les noms
et quand il y à l'information d'une
tribune de valeur actuelle de 1000
militaires qui disent des choses assez
dangereuse et controversé en tous les
cas on ne fait pas un plateau avec 90%
de ceux qui sont là qui soutiennent ce
type de démarche donc je m'appuie sur
des choses précises genou n'a pas le
temps ici de vous parler de chaque chose
mais en ce qui concerne votre propre
responsabilité dont
vous m'avez pas répondu et je note
qu'après monsieur bolloré qui disaient
c'était vous qui savez vous botter en
touche alors que tout le monde sait que
aujourd'hui il y en a pour qui c'est
juste c'est bien ils sont contents et il
y en a d'autres noms que votre chaîne
d'information et très connoté sur le
plan idéologique comme aucune chaîne
d'information qui chacune à c'est
effectivement des tendances dans la
façon de traiter l'information
aucune aujourd'hui n'est sur ce créneau
est en tous les cas n'existe pas dans
les conventions avec le csa est
aujourd'hui d'art comme la possibilité
d'avoir des chaînes d'opinion dans les
fréquences attribuées et en avoir sur le
numérique sur sur internet ça existe
chacun peut même faire sa chaîne mais ça
n'est pas prévu et c'est bien comme ça
après les licenciements de sébastien
thoen pour son sketch sur pascal praud
et celui de stéphane guy pour l'avoir
soutenu
la presse raconte qu'une quinzaine de
salariés ont souhaité vous rencontrer
fin janvier 2021 oui
un participant résume si votre rencontre
et nous dit qu'il comprend notre
souffrance et nous jure qu'il n'y aura
pas de chasse aux sorcières parle de
vous
mais le lendemain alors que vous
encensez le 10 février vous réitérer
cette promesse lors d'une
visioconférence avec la rédaction et
vous encensez l'émission dimanche soir
sport delory delos talent
le lendemain la journaliste qui n'a pas
lui qui est connu pour sa franchise est
déprogrammée licenciés ou la veille vous
disiez qu'il n'y aurait pas de problème
pouvez vous nous expliquer pourquoi
est-ce comme pour monsieur sébastien
thoen où vous aviez indiqué à ce dernier
qu'il est viré sur décision de
l'actionnaire alors que vous comprenez
la souffrance
des gens est debout dit mais moi je n'y
peux rien c'est l'actionnaire un
actionnaire dit que l'une décide de rien
c'est vous qui décidez
et vous avez assumé sur rmc quand on n'a
plus envie de mots c'est quelque part on
prend ses responsabilités on a demandé à
d'autres de partir parce qu'on a envie
de travailler avec des gens qui veulent
travailler avec nous je suis désolé mais
c'est comme ça
que me répondez vous sur ce fait précis
mais bon j'en ai tellement d'autres oui
je suis d'accord il y en a tellement je
sais pas par où commencer
vous avez dit que j'avais dit que ces
news n'est pas une chaîne d'information
insuffisamment ce qu'il faut j'ai jamais
dit ça j'ai dit que c'était pas une
chaîne d'opinion
nous qualifier de trash une chaîne que
vous n'avez jamais regardé c'est
inquiétant
c'est inquiétant pour les 120
journalistes justice au point c'est pas
une chaîne que je regarde régulièrement
comme quand on a un média préféré ne
venez pas essayer d'avoir de polémique
avec moi là dessus je regarde ce que je
veux par contre je peux vous dire que
moi personnellement comme homme
politique et publique j'ai pris la
décision depuis le grand nettoyage que
vous avez fait est que deux avec i télé
au passage à ses news et depuis le fait
qu'il ya cette tendance là de ne
répondre à aucune invitation de ses new
skies le sait très bien et je n'ai pas
mis les pieds sur votre plateau mais
celles pour cette raison on va lancer
répondre de ce stade oui mais laisse
répondre monsieur ça mais si vous
changez d'avis nous serons ravis de vous
recevoir
la chronologie vous avez indiqué thaler
et inexact
le consens c'est l'émission dimanche
soir sport non je n'ai pas fait ce
inexactes
j'aimais bien les missions il
fonctionnait pas et donc on a des
programmes et c'est une décision comme
il y en a beaucoup vous pointez celle là
il y en a beaucoup d'autres
sébastien thoen
a été rémunéré par un tiers pour
dénigrer canal+ c'est un problème pour
moi je l'assumé c'est une décision que
j'ai prise
je ne me dérobe pas comme vous l'avez
semblez le dire tout à l'heure
stéphane guy avait fait l'objet de
nombreuses
nombreuses alertes sur son comportement
à l'antenne où il avait tendance à
exprimer son opinion personnelle pendant
les matches pendant des émissions et on
lui disait que c'était un sujet et
c'était la fois trop en effet il
intervenu sur ce sujet spécifique du
décès d ailleurs par licenciement parce
qu'il n'était pas en cdi au passage
sébastien thoen il été pigiste donc
c'était une fin de collaboration
comme vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure
qu'on avait débarqué des
collaborateurs de ses new skies n'est
pas le cas puisque en fait nous avons eu
recours à une rupture conventionnelle
qui était leur choix le chou à la
demande des salariés concernés qui ont
eu trois semaines pour se positionner
choisir un plan de départ
alors qu'on avait la possibilité
d'exercer une cause de confiance les
intéressés eux mêmes n'avaient pas
souhaité que nous exercions la clause de
confiance enfin exercer leurs clauses de
confiance
et nous avions mis en place avec le
ministère du travail cette rupture
conventionnelle pour pour les 78
salariés concernés
donc oui j'assume totalement la décision
sur sébastien thoen la décision de ses
fans oui c'est moi qui l'ait prise et
pourtant j'étais attaché à ce
journaliste
qui a énormément de qualités par
ailleurs
dernière question du rapporteur après
mes collègues interviennent aux
questions plus générales sur havas
pouvez vous préciser les rapports de
votre groupe avec havas et je vais vous
dire le
je voulais la série de petites questions
concrètes qui vont avec que
répondez-vous aux accusations de
favoritisme
visant l'activité d'havas ce avec les
chaînes de votre groupe l'agent saurait
en effet tendance à favoriser canal+ et
ses filiales ses huit ses stars et ses
news en 2018 ces chaînes ont représenté
12 1% des espaces publicitaires achetés
par havas alors qu'elle ne pesait que
neuf chez les agences concurrentes qu'on
est il de l'achat d'espacés
publicitaires par le groupe canal+ et
opérations pastel exclusivement par
havas
havas analyse les données qu universal
music group ancienne propriété du groupe
vivendi et ses artistes génère au
travers de la vente de leur musique de
la revente de billets des produits
dérivés du streaming des médias sociaux
d écoute radio afin de mieux appréhender
la corrélation que les artistes les fans
de musique et les marques les données
clients du groupe canal + sont elles
utilisées par abbas en vue de développer
nos publicitaires mieux ciblés voilà une
question sont très précises
excusez moi monsieur le rapporteur je
n'ai pas compris la question sur umg
universal music je vais vouloir répéter
à vals analyse les données de universal
music group ancienne propriété du groupe
vivendi mais où est encore d une départ
et ses artistes génère au travers de la
vente de leur musique de la vente des
billets des produits dérivés du
streaming des médias sociaux d écoute
radio afin de mieux appréhender la
corrélation entre les artistes les fans
de musique et les marques je vous pose
la question les données clients du
groupe canal sont elles utilisées par
havas en vue de développer une offre
publicitaire mieux cibler
très bien très clame ainsi alors sur les
12,1 pour cent le chiffre que vous
indiquez totalement exact c'est bien la
part de marché du groupe canal + chez
havas et elle est exactement mais nature
chez tous ses concurrents à l'exception
de publicis dont nous avons le sentiment
qui le nous punit parce que havas fait
partie du groupe vivendi et que canal +
fait partie du groupe des vingt dix
c'est un sujet dont je me suis entretenu
à plusieurs reprises avec arthur sadoun
notamment où nous avons une part de
marché plus tôt 2 9%
mais chez les autres ni comme et où je
pourrais citer toutes les agences et de
l'an de 12%
donc nous n'avons pas du tout le
sentiment pour être précis et de
favoriser par havas au passage on parle
de 34 millions d'euros sur les douze
derniers mois
versé en revenus publicitaires issus
damas pour le groupe canal + 0 6 % du
chiffre d'affaires de canal+ donc un
chiffre assez dérisoire et
accessoirement un chiffre en baisse
puisqu'ils étaient 38 millions l'année
précédente
et pour répondre également précisément à
votre question sur l'utilisation des
données par abbas ce n'est pas le cas
canal+ exploite directement ces données
et quand il les partage avec des
partenaires il est d'ailleurs tenu
d'indiquer à ses à ses abonnés si on le
faisait ça serait indiquée et il
faudrait que nous y soyons autorisé par
les abonnés
merci président bonjour monsieur saâdane
même si une certaine tension est à peine
palpable dans cette salle rené monory
ancien
chapelle
je vais peut-être amené plus de 2 calme
en rapport avec ce que sont les
commission denquête au sénat
si j'osais je dirais que votre formation
votre parcours que vous avez rappelé au
début parce que chez un professionnel
c'est important
ce parcours atteste non pas d'un point
de vue alors là je dors et sans apporter
la contradiction à notre reporter mais
ce n'est pas un point de vue à mon sens
puisque c'est exactement ce que sont
venus nous dire tous les industriels
tous les entrepreneurs et ce n'est pas
un gros mot
devant cette commission d enquête depuis
le début des auditions vous êtes venu
nous dire au début de votre propos les
mécanismes
les réalités concrètes et incontournable
de l'économie mondiale avec laquelle
vous vous débattez avec canal+ vous êtes
la preuve vivante et c'est important et
ô combien
rassurant
que le défi de la taille
est un défi qui peut être relevé par la
france si jamais c'est un défi national
et ça non plus c'est pas un gros mot
devant ces plateformes qui nous arrive
en leur ouvrant les portes comme vous
l'avez décrit où certains pouvoirs ont
favorisé l'arrivée de ces plateformes au
détriment d'entreprises françaises
mais pour parvenir à cette à ce maintien
d'activités il s'agit pas d'être figée
dans le temps sur des combats d'arrière
garde et j'ai l'impression que souvent
nous sommes dans ces combats en france
il s'agit de se concentrer sur ce qui
fait
ce business et ce n'est pas un gros mot
la partie technologie et la partie
contenue
en citant les slogans puisque c'est au
coeur du débat j'ai l'impression les
slogans de ces news la liberté d'opinion
est elle une espèce en voie de
disparition
ou c'est en confrontant les opinions
qu'on s'en fait une ma première question
c'est quelle est votre conception du
rôle de l'actionnaire principal dans un
média et la seconde et j'en aurai
terminé par la pouvez-vous préciser aux
législateurs que nous sommes les freins
principaux et dieu sait s'ils sont
nombreux qu'il faudrait lever pour
permettre aux acteurs français de faire
valoir notre exception culturelle
et ce avec quoi nous rayonnons depuis
des siècles alors que nous sommes grands
comme un timbre poste à la surface du
globe
merci
monsieur le sénateur
le rôle l'actionnaire principal dans un
média tels que j'ai vécu -
c'est un drôle de vision
vision partagée avec vincent bolloré
de la capacité pour un acteur français
du réunionnais de faire rayonner la
culture française européenne à
l'international et de cette opportunité
de marché que j'évoquais dans mon propos
liminaire cette volonté de faire
rayonner la culture de croire en la
culture et en sa force et comme une
alternative est la seule alternative en
réalité aujourd'hui crédible face à
l'hégémonie culturelle américaine qu'on
aime beaucoup par ailleurs qu'on
consomme aussi et qu'on regarde
également
donc ça c'est la première chose c'est
une conviction partagée et cette volonté
construire un acteur industriel qui pèse
au plan mondial
et qui fait rayonner notre culture nos
talents notre histoire nos lieux
dans laquelle nous investissons plus en
plus via studio canal ou via un canal +
et et localement dans tous les
territoires européens et j'ai cité
la deuxième la deuxième chose pour moi
la deuxième vertu j'ai envie terre de
l'actionnaire pour de mon point de vue
de salariés
c'est ce qu'a évoqué vincent bolloré
lors de son audition ici c'est le temps
l'otan qu'ils nous aient laissé la
chance qu'on a chez canal+ de ne pas
être soumis comme d'autres
à la règle quotidienne ou quasi
quotidiennes du cours de bourse qui peut
motiver les décisions dans un sens ou
dans l'autre et cette possibilité de
s'inscrire dans une durée plus longue
elle est absolument crucial
elle nous permet de faire des
investissements dans le long terme elle
nous permet de résister à des événements
ponctuels avec cette vision d'une durée
plus longue elle nous permet de prendre
des risques
financer un film ces trois ans financé
une série versailles que j'étais tout à
l'heure le bureau des légendes ses 5 ans
donc il faut s'inscrire dans cette durée
et c'est une chance
pendant la deuxième question vous
m'aviez posé
pouvez vous préciser aux législateurs
que nous sommes les freins principaux
qu'il faudrait lever pour permettre aux
acteurs français de faire valoir nos
merci il y en a beaucoup mais il y en a
un qui me qui est un sujet pour moi sur
lesquels je reviens à sa ble ment depuis
j'ai des gens parlaient déjà en 2016
sans cesser notre capacité enfin notre
incapacité à détenir des droits
audiovisuels
voilà nous on est toujours dans la même
situation et hélas la nouvelle loi
audiovisuelle a conforté les producteurs
ou cette situation dans laquelle nous
finançons entre 80 et 90% de de fiction
et nous n'en doutons pas les droits qui
sont réservées aux producteurs est ce
qui nous oppose deux sujets le premier
qui est de notre capacité à offrir en
france même sur les marchés où nous
finançons ces séries des droits un peu
plus long céderont la durée de ses
droits a été encore réduite avec la
nouvelle loi de visuels donc on peut se
retrouver dans une situation situation
parlant ce qui nous est arrivé dans le
passé ou au moment où vous proposez la
saison 3 du bureau des légendes vous
n'avez plus la saison un endroit et vous
devez la racheter et potentiellement
refinancer une série vous avez déjà
financé
mais surtout ça rend beaucoup plus
compliqué cette ambition que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure de faire rayonner la
culture française parce que comme des
non pas les droits des séries que nous
finançons en france pour les territoires
de france on se retrouve dans une
situation où aux états unis par exemple
versailles et un netflix le budget n'en
est donc nous ne pouvons pas exploité
ses séries à l'international où il faut
pour le faire se contorsionner trouver
des accords par ailleurs et c'est très
très très compliqué ça c'est vraiment le
premier frein pour le groupe canal+ qui
se retrouve dans une situation hélas
unique parce que c'est le seul opérateur
français je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
même européen à avoir cette ambition
globale mondiale cette présence sur 50
pays donc en fait c'est pas la
problématique des groupes tf1 m6 ou même
france télévisions qui sont sur d'autres
enjeux
monique de marco
merci
merci monsieur saâdane donc je ne
reviendrai pas sur les inquiétudes que
suscite la ligne éditoriale de beauchêne
mais je rappelle quand même que jean
christophe thiery directeur de la
publication de ces news a été condamné
pour condamnation à la haine raciale et
votre chaîne ces news a reçu une amende
de plus de deux cent mille euros par le
csa pour incitation à la haine et à la
violence je reviens plus tôt sur les
propos que vous avez tenus à la fin de
votre introduction
donc effectivement vous avez considéré
qu'il y avait beaucoup de freins qu'il
ne fallait pas entraver davantage donc
donc les médias mais également vous avez
terminé en disant que vous considérez
qu'il que c'est une hypothétique
concentration
c'est votre conclusion vous n'avez pas
cette hypothétique concentration des
médias en france ça pouvez-vous préciser
ses propos
alors sur le premier point je me permets
de revenir sur la décision que vous
citez nous la contestons conseil devant
le conseil d'état
mais je crois avoir évoqué dans mon
propos liminaire le fait qu'en fait en
réalité le marché était aujourd'hui
beaucoup moins concentrés qu'ils ne
l'étaient dans le passé
beaucoup beaucoup moins le pluralisme on
y contribue d'ailleurs largement
canal+ est aussi distributeur de chaînes
je le rappelle est même un des
principaux en france et à
l'international et pour la france nous
distribuons près de 330 chaînes dont
toutes les chaînes d'information
françaises internationales européennes
la bbc cnn mais aussi toutes les chaînes
françaises y compris ivan iv france 24
et d'autres chaînes d'information donc
nous contribuons largement au pluralisme
et dans la mesure où toutes ces chaînes
existent que de nouvelles sont créées
régulièrement
et que sur chacune de ces chaînes d
exprimons diverses
opinions diverses s'expriment je ne vois
pas en réalité la problématique de
concentration
poser problème
pour ce qui est du marché français
je voudrais rappeler aussi pardon que on
parle beaucoup de l'information et de
l'accès à l'information il faut rappeler
quand même qu'en france
les chaînes d'information comme source
d'information
ces 16% le total de toutes les chaînes
d'information 16%
cas pour 46% sont les chaînes
hertziennes
c'est à dire en gros principalement les
13h et de 20h de tf1 et france
télévisions et le jt de m6 qui est qui
est un succès c'est ça dont on parle ça
c'est 46% des sources d'information pour
la population française et ensuite vous
avez un peu près un tiers donc deux fois
les chaînes d'information au total qui
vient d'internet dont on n'a pas encore
parlé ici qui est quand même le vrai
sujet est où là on pourrait se poser des
question de concentration si je peux me
permettre quand on a deux acteurs qui
détiennent 90% à 95% du marché
publicitaire
si on prend les jeunes qui est un sujet
et je pense qu'il nous concerne toutes
les moins de 35 ans les chaînes
d'information c'est moins de 13% hélas
les sources internet pèse pour 60 %
60% des sources d'information pour les
jeunes sont un sujet dont on n'a pas
parlé depuis depuis le début de cette
audition et sa pompe là pour moi ya un
sujet éventuellement
michel laugier merci monsieur le
président monsieur sadove le bonjour
merci pour les réponses très directs qui
sont les vôtres depuis les débuts vous
exprimer au top et non je vais exprimer
la mienne je suis pas la pensée puisque
l'objet de notre commission c'est de
vous questionner dont je vais être
direct et je vais passer à mes questions
on a beaucoup parlé bien sûr la
croissance et des médias nous depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà qui entraîne
bien sur deux enjeux l'enjeu économique
bien sûr et puis non je bien sûr
de l'information de la liberté de
l'information du pluralisme
à propos de l'information juste devant
être quelle est la part factures en
passant à l'information au sein de vos
deux groupes en pourcentage par rapport
par exemple
other écoute de de votre groupe que
représente aujourd'hui l'information
combien de journalistes travaillent pour
pente au groupement pack de ses news
pour votre groupe est ce que ce sont des
effectifs qui sont stables qui sont
évolutifs et puis est ce qu'il ya un
taux de rotation importants ou es ce que
vous avez une certaine de stabilité ça
c'est ma première question la gêne je
voudrais revenir un petit peu quand même
sur
les sanctions ou les où les rappels à
l'ordre du csa aujourd'hui art comme
vous avez eu plusieurs
quelles dispositions avez vous prises
sont aujourd'hui pour la limite soit
rentré dans le rang soit contesté
puisque j'ai bien compris que certaines
étaient contestées et puis
vous avez évoqué mais j'allais le faire
me voyez la question aussi des grandes
plateformes justement on est aujourd'hui
dans un monde des médias qui a largement
évolué quelle est votre stratégie pour
les prochaines années justement par
rapport à cette concurrence avec les
plateformes internationales
merci à vous
anton antenne pour votre première
question je ne saurais pas vous dire on
a
soixantaine de chaînes en france payante
et met à linthal internationale c'est
beaucoup plus est ces news est la seule
chaîne d'information du groupe donc je
dirais que ça pèse sans doute pour moins
de 1 %
en nombre de journalistes donc pour les
cartes de presse de seignosse on parle
de 120 c'est une centaine pour la
rédaction des sports de canal plus
et nous avons beaucoup de journalistes
sur nos territoires à l'étranger je ne
saurais pas vous dire combien non plus
sur le sujet de la conformité alors
évidemment nous nous cherchons à
évidemment à respecter notre convention
et être conforme à toutes les règles
avec le csa et donc nous équipons ce qui
était le cas sur le temps de parole qui
est un travail considérable par une
équipe qui est dédié à temps plein à ce
sujet là
je vous dis à cesser le sait le rôle de
thomas müller que vous avez rencontré de
toutes les équipes de ces news de
chercher à se conformer mais je sais que
ça prend un temps considérable et
d'ailleurs ça parce que je ne critique
en rien parce que pour je sais que pour
le serrer pour l'art comme c'est un
sujet extrêmement compliqué également
voilà pour cette audition au sénat de
maxime saada le patron du groupe canal+
et de la plateforme dailymotion il a
répondu aux questions de la commission
d' enquête du sénat sur la concentration
des médias c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi continu
à suivre l'actualité politique et
parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]